hi bryan luke daily from ferry treatment
technologies youth in innovation and
engagement these are very critical
topics and timely topics especially when
we look at what's happened recently in
Tunisia and Yemen the pace of Technology
engaging youth in allowing innovation to
occur is critical for the formation one
societies in the future of areas like
the Middle East for example that have a
population bulge the majority of the
population is under 25 years old and for
their future to grow and compete on the
world stage they're going to have to
come up with organic ways to foster
innovation in those communities and
societies so innovation and engaging
youth is key and it's our future
everywhere but it's especially important
in places like the Middle East right now
thank you